Last question today, David.
Why are older voters abandoning Trump?
Last week, you talked about why rural white,
older voters like Trump, but now they're abandoning
him.
Why is it basically three reasons appear to
be what's going what's really hurting Donald
Trump in the last week?
This is new.
Before this week, we knew Trump's handling
of Corona virus was hurting him in general
and hurting him with older voters.
Trump's handling of the economy as a result
of coronavirus meaning the economic destruction
was worse than it had to be because of Trump's
mishandling of corona virus that is hurting
Trump with older voters.
But we now, in addition, have the issue of
debate performance.
The post debate polls by Donald Trump, the
post debate polls that account for Donald
Trump.
Trump's performance in the debate are a disaster
for Trump, specifically among older voters.
Older voters in some polls are no longer even
the demographic group age wise that most supports
Trump.
There is a new poll, I think it was the CNN
poll from this week where the under 35 crowd
is actually Trump's strongest group.
From the standpoint of age and what's going
on is that for a lot of older folks, corona
virus is not abstract.
Certainly, if you're in a nursing home and
you see people dying and you see the chaos,
it is not numbers you check once a day.
It is very real.
If you simply know people not nursing home
related who aren't doing well and of course,
because it disproportionately affects older
folks, those are the folks most likely to
have friends and people in their circle that
are suffering directly.
And then you see Trump go on television and
say it's like a flu.
It's no big deal.
We've turned the corner.
Our mark, we're getting great marks.
You see the obvious lies and you know, well,
you know, Blanch died and Joe died.
How is Trump saying this?
Your friends are in ICU use.
That is going to create a problem for you.
And then went on top of it.
You start looking at your retirement account
or you're on a fixed income or Trump's talking
about cutting funding to Social Security by
a payroll tax deferral.
It's not good.
And pretending that this was a hoax was a
very bad idea.
The statistics don't lie.
We said in May when Trump started transitioning
into we beat it, that that might work in June
and July, but it's not going to work forever
and it's not been working.
And then you.
Add to the fact that Hillary Clinton was less
liked than Joe Biden.
Joe Biden, by and large, particularly for
older white folks, is much more likable than
Hillary Clinton.
He's the type of guy most people would like
to sit down and just talk to.
Many older voters would identify with Joe
Biden.
Guy who grew up working class, likes trains,
has suffered significant personal loss and
so on and so forth.
Then you look at Trump and he's just a rude,
disgusting guy who yelled the entire debate.
So all of that together tells us seniors are
paying attention.
They're not willing to die for the economy.
Like the what was his name, Dan Roberts or
Dan Patrick.
The lieutenant governor of Texas said early
on in this thing and they're paying attention.
They're paying attention to what's going on.
Trump, already going into all of this, was
doing less well with seniors than many previous
Republicans had done.
Now it's gotten even worse.
He's got the latest.
Polls in the last 96 hours are very, very
bad.
And hopefully every single one of these groups
will completely repudiate Donald Trump in
a brutal, brutal defeat.
But it's up to us to make it happen.
And we're going to try to do that.
Exactly.
And we will continue pushing next week and
the week after and the week after that.
And then hopefully we'll have a new president
elect.
We have a great bonus show for you today.
Remember, you can get instant access not an
hour from now, not 20 minutes from now.
Instant access to the bonus show by becoming
a member at join Pacman dot com or a patron
at patrie on dot com slash David Pakman show.